let's try instead the 267 area code
caller from 2 6-7 what is your name
where are you calling from and what's
your question today hi David this is
Connor
I'm calling from State College
Pennsylvania alright and I've been
trying I've been meaning to call you in
for a few times now but uh I'm sorry if
there's a little wind I'm walking there
it's at once but alright be careful ok
I'm on the sidewalk good and I just want
to call and ask you if you know of a
fellow youtuber called named Colin
Moriarty and if you have or even even if
you haven't if you've considered getting
him on the show because he's like a big
quote libertarian side just like Dave
Rubin is right and I really enjoyed the
full show that you had with David Rubin
because nobody really calls these guys
out on their you know questionable
beliefs here's the thing so Connor I am
familiar with Colin Moriarty only
insofar as I watched 5 minutes of him on
the Dave Rubin show and he struck me as
one of these guys who presents his hip
and if I recall correctly he's got
tattoos and whatever else but he is
ideologically pretty committed to some
really bad ideas and I don't think that
they were challenged by Dave Rubin
there is a my sort of on track
absolutely yeah so I'm not against
interviewing him the thing is he is he's
really an unknown to our TV and radio
audience so if I did it I think it would
have to be like a YouTube only thing
which would be fine I think but I don't
know and I don't know that he's
interested in being interviewed by me
either
yeah I could see that I think that you
take time Sargon was awesome I think
that things when you get to talk to
people like Ben Shapiro like these
people that you interact with like
you're the only one that I think is not
I wouldn't say you're the only one
that's qualified but you're the only one
that consistently being able to take
down these people with logic and reason
without getting too like heated in
debate so me and my roommate have been
trying to get through and talk to you
about this and I thought it'd just be a
good idea to have him on the show even
if it was
to YouTube only I thought it'd be cool
to see you guys interact and go back and
forth a little bit all right we will
research appreciate the call Connor
where you headed to lunch by the way I'm
going to the Dining Commons even though
I'm seeing here I got a meal plan so got
it God I got a Penn State what's like
the oh do you wow that's a whole other
can of worms but let's not get into that
what what what's the good item at the
Penn State Dining Commons um well it
wouldn't be for Pat but the
cheeseburgers are pretty good we'll have
to say and the pizza and the pizza but
you know Pat can't have any of that
right always the cheeseburgers of the
pizza yeah cheeseburgers in pizza all
right Connor great to hear from you
thanks for calling in thanks taking my
call all right no problem Wow
very very exciting stuff